ahora que hemos explorado el teorema de
stocks un poquito quiero hablar de las
situaciones en las que podemos usarlo
verás que realmente este es un teorema
bastante general pero tenemos que pensar
en qué tipo de superficies y qué tipo de
fronteras vamos a tratar y en el caso
del teorema de stocks tenemos dos cosas
a considerar la curva frontera que
define a nuestra superficie y la misma
superficie entonces primero hablemos un
poquito de la superficie en realidad
ésta debe ser suave por trozos ok suave
por trozos qué quiere decir que una
superficie sea suave por trozos
esencialmente estamos pensando en que la
derivada de las derivadas parciales sean
continuas por ejemplo supongan sé
ustedes que tienen un punto sobre la
superficie y aquí estamos viendo la
derivada parcial respecto de una
variable y aquí el vector derivada
respecto a otra variable esencialmente
lo que nos están diciendo estos vectores
son cambios graduales de la pendiente en
una u otra dirección así
esta palabra que sea suave en realidad
nos está diciendo que tenga derivadas
parciales voy a desdecir solo derivadas
continuas ok es decir que los cambios
sean graduales sean poquito a poquito no
sean muy bruscos por ejemplo y bueno
también nos dice que sea por trozos y
les voy a dar aquí un ejemplo que tengo
a mi derecha tengo una lata en donde
pongo todos mis y todas mis plumas y
todos mis lápices más o menos tiene esta
forma
algo así por ejemplo si fuera un poquito
transparente veríamos esta parte de
atrás y para que se vea que realmente no
tiene esta parte de arriba no tiene una
tapa aquí voy a poner una de mis plumas
que tengo
esta es una de mis plumas
y bueno el detalle es el siguiente esta
superficie que es como un cilindro
esencialmente si en la tapa es suave por
trozos no es suave por sí misma porque
por ejemplo si nosotros tenemos una
pendiente que va en esta dirección
cuando nosotros pasamos a este punto
hace un brinco hace que la pendiente
brinque de forma muy brusca verdad
entonces no es suave en un conjunto como
tal de forma global pero si es suave por
trozos porque ésta la puedo descomponer
en dos superficies que son suaves ok por
ejemplo que es una de ellas es esta que
es digamos el muro que define el
cilindro que sale y la otra es la tapa
esta de acá abajo que es simplemente una
circunferencia un círculo ok entonces ya
que pude descomponer esta superficie en
dos superficies que si son suaves
completitas entonces eso es que sea
suave por trozos
otra cosa que hay que considerar es la
curva frontera está ce la curva frontera
hay que pedirle que sea cerrada ok y que
también sea simple cerrada y simple por
supuesto también vamos a tener que
pedirle suave por trozos suave por
trozos vamos a explicar cada una de
estas cosas primero que sea simple que
una curva sea simple es que no cometa
auto intersecciones por ejemplo esta
curva si yo la voy recorriendo de esta
forma en realidad no es simple porque
tuve una auto intersección ok entonces
ésta no es simple aunque la puedo partir
digamos de esta forma en dos curvas que
si son cerradas y simples que es una
curva cerrada pues justamente que de
dónde empiezo yo termino por ejemplo
esto no es una curva cerrada yo tendría
que regresar al punto original entonces
una curva cerrada así es por ejemplo no
se puede hacer cosas muy locas
de donde empiezo tengo que regresar al
final ok esto es una curva cerrada y por
último que una curva sea suave por
trozos pues esencialmente es igual que
con las superficies por ejemplo aquí les
voy a mostrar una curva que no es suave
pero si es suave por trozos ok este
cuadrilátero por ejemplo lo podemos
partir en cuatro curvas suaves esta
primera curva tiene la pendiente está
bastante sencillita es una es un
segmento de recta pero por ejemplo si yo
fuera en esta en este segmento llegó a
este punto y me sigo hago un brinco hago
un cambio muy brusco en cómo va
cambiando la pendiente pero yo puedo
partir esta curva en cuatro segmentos
que
por sí mismos son suaves entonces esta
curva es es suave por trozos además de
ser cerrada y simple entonces si tenemos
una superficie que es suave por trozos y
su frontera es una curva simple es decir
que no comete auto intersección es que
es cerrada es decir que de donde inició
regreso al final y suave por trozos
entonces se puede utilizar muy bien el
teorema de stocks